in economics supply and demand is a
basic model which states that in a
competitive market the price of the good
or service will vary until the quantity
demanded equals the quantity supplied
with an increase in demand also comes an
increase in price which persuade sellers
to supply more of that economic good but
what happens when the good in question
is human bodies well in the early 19th
century the Scottish capsule of
Edinburgh was one of Europe's leading
bastions of medical knowledge
particularly when it came to Anatomy
bourbon research into this area caused a
huge demand for cadavers for dissection
in turn this led to the rise of ghoulish
resurrection men or Body Snatchers as we
would call them today who dig up corpses
and sell them to surgeons who were more
often than not willing to just look the
other way
bizarrely the most infamous of these
resurrectionists never actually dug up a
body in their lives indeed to death of
happenstance caused the duo to realize
that creating bodies was far easier and
a lot less messy than digging them up
and so it was that William Burke and
William hare embarked on one of the most
gruesome killing sprees in the history
of Scotland
[Music]
details our scans regarding the early
lives of Burke and Hare
booth what irishman the former is born
in Ernie counted Tehran
while the latter may have been a native
of the parish of Nuri County our mark
though we do not know for sure
Burke was a military man who first
married a woman named Margaret Coleman
in Ireland who bore into children around
1817 he moved to Scotland to work as a
navy on the Union canal he met and
married Helen mcdougal who may or may
not have assisted later in her husband's
murder spree William hair is a much more
obscure figure and there is almost no
hard evidence of his life in Ireland he
too was once employed as a navy on the
Union Canal and then he moved to
Edinburgh where he worked various odd
jobs and was relatively skilled as a
cobbler he shacked up with a widow named
Margaret Laird who ran a lodging house
in the city's old town sometime during
the mid 1820s Burke and ham met and
became friends and although neither of
them had a history of violence or a
criminal record it would not be long
before they committed their first murder
together
in order to better understand the
actions of Birkin hair we should take a
moments to talk about
anatomy and how it was perceived in
society throughout most of history
Anatomy was vilified by the common man
the idea of dissecting a body mortified
most people and so the act was typically
performed in secrecy in Scotland human
dissection was outlawed until King James
the fourth allowed barber surgeons to
dissect certain criminals who had been
executed the murder act of 1750 - went a
step further and made the dissections
open to the public this change it served
to intensify the punishment for murder
not to enhance medical knowledge denying
criminals proper burial and instead
having them dissected and put on public
display was meant to add a horrific
extra deterrent to the death penalty but
it also provided more bodies - anatomist
working in hospitals and medical
teaching centres so well that was a plus
even say the interest of medical men in
dissection had reached an apex and the
supply of corpses still proved to be
woefully insufficient thus the
Resurrectionist trade it began to
flourish the money was good especially
for a fresh body and the practice it was
relatively safe from a legal point of
view bag then corpses were not
considered property so those who possess
them were free to sell them without
fearing any reprisal from the law it was
the crime of violation of sepal cos that
usually led to resurrection men being
finds and imprisons of course despite
this legal protection the general public
found Body Snatchers particularly
loathsome
if they were discovered the resurrection
men were typically at the mercy of their
captors which was often rather lacking
the clients of this macabre industry
included some of the most respectable
medical men of their day this is
perfectly exemplified by the story of
one of the most coveted corpses of all
time that of Charles Byrne also known as
the Irish giant at seven feet seven
inches he was considered the tallest man
in the United Kingdom bodies with
unusual features or freaks as they were
called bluntly back in the day commands
at much higher prices than your typical
cadaver Vern knew that anatomist s--
were chomping at
the bit to get their hands on his body
after his death and was horrified by the
idea of being dissected he was proven
right as when burn passed away in 1783
at the age of twenty-two one newspaper
reported that surgeons surrounded his
house like harpooners wood an enormous
whale burn had arranged with his friends
to be sealed in a lead coffin and buried
at sea but his preparations they proved
to be for naught at a time when a body
fetched up to ten pounds one of the most
distinguished Scottish surgeons in
history John Hunter allegedly bribed the
undertaker five hundred pounds to remove
the Giants corpse and replace it with
stones according to the Bank of
England's that is over seventy four
thousand dollars in modern currency
regardless of the costs both moral and
financial hunter got his prize and even
today burn skeleton resides in the
Hunterian Museum in London's Royal
College of Surgeons of England at the
moment there is actually a push for the
museum to surrender possession of the
remains and give them a burial at sea as
per Charles Burns's wishes you know even
if it's 240 years to light
[Music]
all right so let's get back to birkin
half their first victim was not actually
murdered he was an old army pensioner
named Donald who lodged at the house
owned by hair and lad he died in
November of 1827 of dropsy a swelling of
soft tissue caused by excess fluids that
we today refer to as an edema what
matters to her however was that the old
man died still owing him four pounds in
rent money hair turned back for help in
dealing with Donald's corpse and then
came up with the idea of selling it to
the surgeons to recover his losses the
duo then went through a gratuitous
ordeal to keep possession of the body
while making it look like that had it
buried first the carpenter brought them
the coffin and then the three of them
placed the recently deceased Donald
inside and nailed the lid down after the
carpenter left Bergen Harry opens the
coffin took the body out and hid it
under a bed they then packed the empty
box tightly with tannaz bark covered it
with a shoes and then nailed it down
again the plan worked except for the
fact that it was completely unnecessary
since under Scottish law they were
legally free to sell the body Birkin how
went in search of professor of anatomy
Alexander Monro whether or not there was
a previous connection between these
groups is unknown but the pair likely
found out about him and the newspapers
as he was featured for his dissections
of executed criminals instead they found
a man who referred them to dr. Robert
Knox in surgeon's Square there they were
paid 7 pounds and 10 shillings for
Donald's body since the army pensioner
owed him rent her took the bigger cart
of the four pounds five shillings which
still left three pounds and five
shillings for Burke just for lugging a
corpse around the two simply could not
believe their luck that was a lot of
money for easy work with no questions
asked as they were getting ready to
leave the premises one of Knox's
assistants told them that they would
love to do more business in the future
if only they could get more dead bodies
[Music]
alright so the exact timeline of the
murders that took place is a bit fuzzy
after he was apprehended Burke gave two
confessions separate times that had
inconsistencies between them at the same
time they differed from the confession
provided by hair even so most historians
agree that their next target and their
true first victim was a man named Joseph
another tenant who resided in hares
house Joseph who may or may not have
been a Miller
was ill and delirious with a fever back
in her reasons that he was not long for
this world and so all they would be
doing is hurrying along the process a
little bit how had extra motivation to
get rid of him as the presence of the
sickly man did not do wonders for his
business the criminal duo plied him with
whiskey one of them then murdered him by
suffocation while the other sat on his
body to restrain his movements but I can
help
likely employed this killing method to
avoid making any noise but it also had
the added benefit of leaving the cadaver
unmarked and undamaged this technique
later became known as burking the most
likely next victim was an English
salesman whose name has been lost to
history he came to Edinburgh to ply his
wares and took up residence with the
hares
he fell ill with jaundice while staying
there and again William hare was worried
that his presence would drive away other
prospective tenants he and Burke
disposed of the Englishman and the same
manner as Joseph like before dr. Knox
paid top dollar for his body and did not
ask any questions of course the killer's
could not rely on a steady supply of
people walking into his lodging house
and falling ill therefore they started
luring people to the lodge knowing that
it was unlikely that anyone would miss
them next up was Abigail Simpson in
February of 1828 she was a pensioner who
lived a few miles from Edinburgh and
regularly came to the city to sell salt
she stayed at a lodging house where had
got a too drunk to return home he and
his accomplice booked her during the
night and promptly took her body to
surgeons square another old woman was
killed in the same manner
later that month or perhaps in early
March
[Music]
arguably the first notable scrap of the
dastardly duo occurred when they started
targeting prostitutes by the nature of
their work they were more well known
around the city than pensioners and
traveling salesmen in April Burke met
two ladies of the night Janice Brown and
Mary Patterson also known as Mary
Mitchell back then
they were referred to as girls of the
town which meant that at least part of
their income came from prostitution
Burke invited the two women to have
breakfast with him at his brother's home
Constantine Burke lived nearby with his
wife and two children but he left for
work
soon after the trio arrived Patterson
got drunk and passed out
Helen mcdougal also came to the house
and got into an argument with Burke over
the presence of the young woman whether
or not this was planned is hard to say
but Jenny brown excused herself and left
when she returned to find her friends
Patterson had disappeared with Burke she
was already dead by this point and she
was headed for noxus dissecting table
Patterson's corpse was more suspicious
than the ones brought before several of
the surgeon's assistants recognized her
most likely because they once turned to
her for her speciality services one of
them even knew her by name is Mary
Mitchell the body was young it had no
signs of illness and clearly had never
been buried they questioned Burke as to
where he got it and he replied that he
obtains the corpse from an old lady in
the Canongate this was obviously a lie
as he might as well have said that he
tripped over it while walking down the
street and yet the medical men they did
not press the matter as Phenix himself
he was so delighted with the quality of
the cadaver that he ignored any peculiar
details he preserved the body and
whiskey for three months before finally
dissecting it and even brought a painter
in to immortalize it in a sketch this
actually worked in the physicians favor
during the trial because his defenders
argued that had Knox known that
Patterson was a murder victim he surely
would not have flaunted her with so much
enthusiasm Mary Patterson became the
most notorious victim of Burke and Hare
probably because her story captivated
the public the most
Jana Braun probably helped as well she
offered her witness testimony at the
trial but it proved unnecessary to
secure a conviction so instead she told
her story to the newspapers even though
Mary Peterson raised a few questions the
victims were still plentiful throughout
the spring of 1828
all of them were women who were brought
to their households were offered copious
amounts of cheap liquor and then
smothered when they passed out among the
victims were a mother-daughter duo
called Mary and Peggy Haldane who were
worked months apart perhaps the most
heinous murders happened that summer
when Birkin hair killed two lodgers who
consisted of an old woman and her
grandson who was mentally disabled while
the old woman was dispatched in the
usual method Burke allegedly slayed the
boy by lifting him up and breaking his
back over his knee we cannot say for
sure that he did this so maybe it was an
accident or maybe the killer sadistic
side was really starting to show
[Music]
the second-to-last victim in the
gruesome murder spree was a young
vagrant named James Wilson he was
mentally disabled and had a bum leg and
was known by the locals as daft
Jamie the killer went smoothly at first
but there were problems when Jamie ended
up on Knox's Anatomy table some of the
students recognized him around the same
time that word spread around the
community that daft Jamie had gone
missing allegedly this course Knox to
dissect the vagrants ahead of schedule
he removed Jamie's heads and legs which
gave him the distinct limp thus making
the body unrecognizable if true this
certainly implements dr. Knox showing at
the very least that he did not want any
scrutiny into the source of his cadavers
Birkin has last kill it took place on
the 31st of October
she was an Irish woman named Margaret
dirty she was staying at the same
lodging house as Burke and MacDougall
which belonged to his cousin John Brogan
problematically there was another family
in the building James and Ann grey the
greys was sent to stay at the hair house
for the night while hair went over to
help Burke killed Doherty the next
morning however the greys returned and
found a woman's body hidden in a pile of
straw they went to the police and
reported the crime by the time they had
arrived to search the lodging house
Perkins hair had taken the body to
surgeons scrab but already still found
dirties blood-stained clothes hidden
under a bet like with the rest of their
victims back and hair kept the meager
possessions that Doherty hat even under
the circumstances they apparently didn't
think it necessary to throw away our
clothes police were convinced there was
foul play at work they went to dr.
Knox's hospital where James gray
identified the body of Mary dirty as the
women killed by Burke and Hare
[Music]
after 10 months and 16 murders the
killing spree was over Berk her Laird
and mcdougal had all been arrested
initially they only had been charged
with the slaying of Margaret dirty
authorities knew there were more victims
and eventually so did the public thanks
to rumors and sensationalist media
reporting soon enough every missing
person in Edinburgh was thought to have
fallen prey to the remorseless Anatomy
murderess without any bodies authorities
knew that it would be hard to prove that
any of the other murders had taken place
so they made a deal full immunity from
prosecution for the one who turned
King's evidence and gave a detailed
account of all the killings whatever
reason Hera was offered the deal first
and unsurprisingly he readily accepted
spousal privilege meant that he could
not testify against his wife Margaret
heir so she was off the hook as well her
made a full confession and the
prosecution decided that they had enough
evidence to go to trial later once Peck
realized that only the gallows awaited
him he gave his account of the killings
as well Berks the butcher has the thief
Knox the man who buys the beef those
words were part of a rhyme that
circulated on the streets of Edinburgh
after the anatomy murders they reflected
the public opinion regarding the
involvement of dr. Robert Knox in the
killing spree even at a time when buying
corpses from disreputable sources was a
common practice obtaining murder victims
was still considered a heinous act
Knox's detractors argued that there was
no way that someone with his medical
knowledge would not at least have cause
to be suspicious of back in hair he
certainly would have noticed that the
bodies that the two brought to him had
never been buried which should have been
an immediate red flag
the surgeon explains this issue away by
saying that as far as he knew birkin
hair were in the habit of keeping an eye
on lodging houses for the poor and
buying the bodies of the recently
deceased before anyone had made funeral
arrangements for them an investigation
into Knox's actions was headed by Sir
Robert christeson a future president of
the Royal College of Physicians of
Edinburgh he considered that the doctors
role in the murder spree was
reprehensible and immoral but not
against the law in the end the
authorities did not pursue any charges
against Robert Knox
[Music]
the trial started in late December Burke
and MacDougall had only been accused of
three murders those of Margaret dirty
Daft Jamie Wilson and Mary Patterson
these were the three strongest cases
against them
the defense went for a
divide-and-conquer strategy and argued
that it wasn't fair for his client to be
charged with unconnected killings in a
trial where the other defendant had no
concern with two of the offences the
judge agreed with this reasoning and
concluded that each murder had to be
tried separately the prosecution headed
by Sir William Ray decided to start with
the slaying of Mary dirty since it had
the most solid evidence the jury took
less than an hour to deliberate and
unsurprisingly found William Berg guilty
Helen mcdougal was given the Scottish
verdict of not proven or the bastard
verdict as it is more colorfully known
and was released her common-law husband
however was sentenced to death and
public dissection although only one man
was punished by the law for this ghastly
crime spree
several people were involved whose exact
roles are a bit of a mystery to this day
how is Constantin Burke involved or John
Brogan according to Burke's confession
four people were killed in his cousin's
lodging house was he truly unaware of
the grim goings-on in his own home and
what about the wives most likely they
never actually helped murder anyone but
they certainly knew of their husband's
actions and even brought some of the
victims to the lodging houses that made
the shocking revelation that Margaret
hair even tried to convince the men to
kill Helen MacDougall because as a
Scottish woman she was untrustworthy the
courts might have spared MacDougall and
the hares but the mobs were still out
for their blood on several occasions
they had to be protected by the police
from angry people looking for street
justice eventually they all left
Edinburgh individually and vanished into
the mists of history there were rumours
that had died as a blind beggar in
London although this was more wishful
thinking than an actual credible report
Robin Knox was obliged to resign as
permission and became a pariah of the
Scottish medical world eventually he
relocated to London William Burke was
hanged on January the 28th 1829 in front
of tens of thousands of people his body
was dissected
and his skeleton preserved it is still
on display at the anatomical Museum of
the Edinburgh medical school while his
pan skin was used to bind a pocket work
and a calling card case suffice to say
the people of Edinburgh considered that
there was nothing gruesome enough that
they could do to Burke's body that would
equal the pain and the suffering that he
had caused alongside William hare
so really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this every day of the
week also if you're looking for more
from me I've got another channel called
today I found out I'm gonna link to that
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]